hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to a very Christmas
themed three scary games just because
Christmas is over doesn't mean that we
can't bundle up get cozy and enjoy the
tears of Santa Claus finding his way
into your home at night this game is
called this game is called sleigh bells
I don't exactly remember what the name
of the game is in this isn't exactly
telling me but I need to press any key o
sleigh bells
that's it who may who the hell made this
Blake McKinnon okay
Brianna McKinnon okay controls woz shift
left click zoom flashlight interact
objective is either or queue I don't
know which one that is but let's go into
it Christmas Eve and I'm still taking my
clothes off in this horrible town for
money oh I guess that's what I'm doing
ha I better deliver Billy's Christmas
present before it gets too late I wonder
if he even remembers what I look like he
hasn't seen me for months not since he
went to live with his father why'd they
have to take him from me I miss my
little Billy alright Billy I hope I
don't have my clothes off in the middle
of winter right now flashlight on
flashlight off zoom in zoom out
objective deliver Billy's present okay
got it
I don't know why I have a radar that
seems like a very strange thing to need
in my profession but you know anything
that keeps me safe and steps people from
creeping up on me so it seems to be
going a weird way riskier to display
your crew oh hi taxi all right fine then
what happens if I run in this is a
stupid idea
don't please God oh I'm so nimble I'm so
nimble and so quick okay I guess saying
the arrow in the radar is kind of
pointing me in the direction I need to
go because seems to be counterintuitive
your objectives are marked on the yellow
on the mini-map with yellow dots okay
all right oh hi how are you doing hey
good to see you
all right are you cold fine Merry
Christmas
Oh what happened here oh wait yellow dot
there we go there we go this way
hello here is this it no what's going on
with the whole police thing yeah AUSA
fir officers officers hello hello all
right
nothing to say to me I got a flashlight
to go with someone murder back there oh
[ __ ] Santa Claus some one of the elves
oh boy okay all right then you have a
lovely day I'm gonna go this way
you take care of yourself now you hear
take care of yourself it's good to see
oh okay no need to do that completely
unnecessary
I find then uh here we go I'll just
leave the present here I doubt they'll
want to see me right now
am i butt naked am I just completely
butt ass naked right now I better get
home before it gets too late I don't
want to be out after midnight
Merry Christmas Billy wow this is sad oh
hi hey how you doing hello nah nothing
okay all right then well see you around
he's gonna go home wherever home maybe
home is where I go okay did I just not
notice you or you did I walk right by
you guys not see you I have no idea I
think the arrow is still probably
pointing me in the objective direction
oh I see oh I was supposed to go to the
police afterwards hey can I get home I
wonder what's going on here I won't be
getting home this way I guess I'll have
to go through the subway tunnel it's not
mad that much further yeah okay all
right I'll go through this subway tunnel
that that makes perfect sense
up this way I'm guessing some way kinda
reminds me a little bit of cry of fear
which I haven't played in ages and ages
but a little does what if that game
still holds up tasty burger tasty map
tasty hot sausage tasty cat-and-mouse
experiment that's a little different one
of these things is not like the other
Mary Chris oh that's a problem
he's been disemboweled what sort of
maniac would do such a thing I better
get out of here before whoever did this
comes back yeah actually that's a that's
a smart move I'll better get out of here
[Applause]
yeah I doubt it's gonna let me go this
way but I'm gonna try nonetheless it's
not gonna work till it's locked
okay so I can't go the way I came which
means that I just got to go further down
which makes total sense yeah definitely
the murderer wouldn't be in the subway
hmm oh that's peculiar that's
interesting I see okay Santa Claus Santa
Claus is in these sewers with the subway
with me sorry it's in this subway
restaurant with me oh I'm in the
bathroom I didn't quite expect that to
be a thing all right cool good hi Santa
Quaid are you patrolling or do I
actually need to wait a minute wait a
minute wait a minute wait wait wait wait
wait what wait is he just patrolling did
I did I got him whoa grab that please
he's killing policemen now what a
monster can I pick the gun okay I'll
take this no bullets oh damn it oh god
I'm never gonna be able to shoot Santy
Claus so I got actually avoid I didn't
know that he was actually there oh god
where is he
oh there he is
okay just you wait till I get some
bullets simple Santy Claus you're gonna
you're gonna get it you're gonna get it
you are you're gonna get it okay I need
some bullets okay we gone I need some
bullets and then I sure hope that wasn't
a maniacal Santa Claus immediately
behind me okay it was good Oh goober I
don't know if that's entirely true but
I'm gonna believe you now I got crazy
monster kickers when I'm cornered I kick
like a mule how many people know this
but if I am a stripper as it was
suggesting my legs are immensely strong
from working I'll just go I'm gonna go
up well there's no need to ho ho ho this
way I don't know where I'm going
where am I gonna go where am I gonna go
I'm gonna run a stamina how close are
you
oh you're fast I should have known I
should have known the Santa Claus oh god
please no no no no please don't murder
me oh I would love to get stamina back
immediately now okay
do you have pull it pull it pull it it's
been cut up fast I'm being murdered
right now I am mu tau it's a little
delayed on the blood okay this is a
problem there's a big problem there's a
big oak rubber whoa
I know I wanted that no no Louie we we
we what
okay
oh wow okay I got the crowbar I just
need to get out of here
that's all I need to do oh oh all right
oh I'm all the way hey I got a hand oh
yeah that'll that'll do that'll do the
trick this is gonna do it yeah it's you
wait just you waited Santa Claus about
bop you one right on the nog right on
the eggnog if you know what I mean
ah all right I'm gonna go this way I
know which way to go so I just got to go
for it before he can see me easy as pie
okay so where was it again uh it was
this way where did I run like a madman I
think over here there she is there she
is it says this should says there's
something over here oh oh oh oh whose
bullets there was bullets in there I
could have shot Santa I'm gonna shoot
Santa oh I'm so gonna shoot Santa Claus
oh but I have to go all the way back for
the bullets is it worth it I don't even
think it's worth it I don't even think
it might be worth it it might not
actually be worth it maybe it'd be worth
it maybe if I should Santa Claus it
might be worth it I didn't think I'd
actually say those words but whatever
okay that's good because now the man the
mouse sensitivity is just so low in this
game I don't know if he's like on the
way back here from there I try to keep
some stamina
okay okay we're good
I'm assuming he's down here I assumed
correctly God Rick god dammit I didn't
know that he would be right there so I'm
gonna go grab the gun and wait for him
to pass by again oh wait where is he oh
god I'm so impatient I am the least
patient human being on the planet I'm so
dumb that was really dumb that was dumb
that was just so dumb I have the word in
if I was in a horror movie I'd die so
fast Oh God okay bullets a blast Santa
Claus I'm bout to blast him well yeah
it's Santi boy we're yet or yet Claus
man does he spawn only when I pick up
the Kroeber oh yeah okay I knew it I
knew it I knew it I'm coming for you I'm
gonna shoot you okay I don't have enough
bullets for you was I supposed hit every
shot because I didn't like second time
around the bend that's the good one
okay okay once okay I'm just gonna go
for it because this didn't work out at
all my plan was not good my aim was
terrible I again like it's that scene
from Reservoir Dogs I just are not
Reservoir Dogs Who am I doing that other
movie I can't remember the name right
now Shawshank Redemption no that wasn't
it I don't remember what the movie was
Pulp Fiction how was it Pulp Fiction got
it there's like pulp fiction did shot a
bunch of bullets in everything got it
great this is great this is so good I
made it I survived the nightmare is over
and I am free and clear Billy got the
present and I'm a-okay I will never
begin be bothered by Santa Claus very
quiet all of a sudden I wonder where
everyone is gone Santa couldn't possibly
have killed everyone except that would
be entirely possible as Santa Claus can
make it around the world to deliver
presents he probably could be around the
world to deliver broken necks and access
to the spines of all his victims in no
time fine this is fine this is very good
very good and very fine oh hey how's it
going there Oh why do they have to keep
locking this gate I'm so close to
getting home it looks damn East I might
be able to break it down with something
oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah yeah here why
don't you just take the road dear house
oh why do you got to live in the back
alley of a back alley of a back alley
bug give your car don't run Santy Claus
over I don't even know if there's a way
to shoot a me just thank you where you
going are you going buddy oh yeah oh ho
ho ho and stuff ho ho where'd you go
where need to go where did he go how did
he just appear there at least you can't
possibly see me it couldn't possibly see
me but maybe if I put an axe in his
maybe that'll teach him a lesson that no
our prizes kill me all right let's do
this Santa Claus at the close your ears
we're good we're good let's go home I
guess Oh what is this eviction notice
I'm only a few days late on my payment
they must have changed the locked in
like he won't work I need to get out of
here before Santa find B the only way
out there's a lot of the drained rags
Oh God perfect
good great ah where is said train track
well this is a dead end
oh I need to go ah piss up is to go on
the up train that's what it is sure up
Santa Claus doesn't come chasing after
me now it's uh can be totally out of
character okay oh ah just a nice walk
along the train tracks but naked with
Santa Claus chasing after me and on that
ax in my hand that has the blood of a
murder victim on it oh great great
bullets these work perfectly last time
I'm sure they'll work again there's a
lot of dead police around that
especially looks like I did something
but I definitely didn't wasn't me at all
who could even suspect that it was
someone like me okay there's another axe
how many axes do I need more bullets
okay I got 24 bullets if this doesn't
take down Santa Claus I don't think
anything well whatever let me go to this
door down here see what's up with this
it seems safe no no no back up no no no
not like oh god you [ __ ] I was facing
the wrong way god you're such a douche I
hate you I hate you I hate you saying I
said it Christmas is over I can say it
now I hate you
what a dick move right as I'm out of
stamina - now what a douche what a
douche what a douche all right Santa you
want to go I'm loaded to the tits with
bullets and you are about to be loaded
to the tits with holes
where's your weak spot Santa where's
your a weak spot you wimp yeah he's not
a wimp he's surprisingly tough and
surprisingly how no no you don't know
God
great great good great all right here we
go santa claus if that is your real name
which I know it's not yeah yeah that's
what I thought okay gonna go this way
gonna go this way
bye round corners I bet that's gonna get
some distance on him and now all I got
to do oh yeah this is how we do there's
only one other long hallway in this oh
yeah you're dead good game everybody
glad glad I was able to kill Santa all
right pretty good I liked it I was a
little slow going but not too shabby not
too shabby all all right this one's
called
the thirstiest time of the year a game
jam something you can't really call this
game I don't know what that means but
let's see what happens
Dean being alone on the Christmas night
isn't that bad when you think about it
given that the whole house is in your
possession oh you should probably check
the door don't rush opening though we
don't know who's on the other side right
who's we
oh hi that's peculiar
oh the Grimm oh hi okay yeah that's fine
I guess it's it's Locke broan job maze
the cranberry ghost you should hide and
find a way to deal with him I'm sorry
what weird rumor I know but I hear he
fears Fanta
we aren't losing got some in the kitchen
what
oh just in case you were wondering
questioning the voices in your head I'm
your kind of Christmas spirit you're
welcome of course
wait what throw this in him to
neutralize him for a moment what I'm so
confused
hi I got throw this on him right okay
hey okay all right here we go and whoa
nice Naruto run okay all right yeah oh
that's not good how fast are you la bro
and jaha maze oh no he's pretty quick do
I have another can on me I hope I do
here we go I pick up okay I can pick up
more than one that's pretty plus my
wasted all my cranberry he spooked me
good
oh he's oh he could see B oh that's not
good well you can't get me if he can't
catch me through the trees
this might be one of the dumbest things
I've ever seen in my life here we go
okay he busted the door ready for you
where are you bad yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah you're a mistake oh yeah
sucks for you seek help at the gas
station they'll be able to help me with
a refreshing spray alright were you out
where you end yeah yeah yeah try me try
me try me try me you won't you can't you
don't you shan't you Fanta I can't
believe I'm trying why am I trying I
have no idea sir way to sneak out or is
the front door the only way what's that
yeah you want in you can't no no no I
don't
oddly enough weirdo coming come here
did you bug my door did you try to break
it and it didn't break did you just
punch me through a door guys getting on
my nerves I normally have nerves of
steel but this guy's gettin ran on him
come on we're yeah yeah Oh poopy man we
don't know oh you don't know oh you
Oh Oh God he knows no no no no you don't
know you don't know you don't know you
don't know okay
none of this Wow no none of that that
what is that what is that what is that
what is that what is that the crap slide
what is that this is so stupid why am I
trying at this why am i trying why do I
try it this why is this something I'm
trying why am i trying it's obviously a
broken stupid game why am i trying we
get love ran no no no no no no oh no
he's coming okay you better not do the
stupid slide there is okay he didn't
slide he did not slide no no no no no no
point there you go there you do not
slide help help I'm being chased by the
cranberry goes well I guess you saved
huh I yeah I may be and even though
Christmas is ruined for you at least
you're alive right sure I've no one's
here to help me I guess either way
thanks for playing this excuse of a game
for the scrim Jim beautiful ten out of
ten twelve out of twelve thirteen
thousand out of twelve thousand nine
hundred ninety-nine I love it I would
play it another twenty times but you
know I got to move on I'll play it on my
own
later I guess okay so this game is
called Oh it's Christmas Brian wakes up
in the middle of the night bearing
witness to Christmas cheer laid before
him
nostalgia overwhelms him thinking of all
the great times he spent with his family
and his late uncle as he gathers himself
from his slumber he recalls he had been
alone here for months who set all of
this up yawn oh I'm completely and
utterly okay with all this
all right Christmas tree it feels like
plastic it can't hurt to open one of the
mysterious gift from the netherworld Oh
gold artifact well it's definitely
mysterious what is it I don't know but
the music's too loud turn that music
down a couple more notches that's good
right there no wait
raise it up just 1/100 of a percent
higher if you go above that I swear to
God alright this obviously goes here the
lack of dust here is disturbing yeah
well let's put that here
it fits why was it wrapped in a gift why
am I asking those gifts weren't from me
anyways not from anyone as far as I know
oh there's a note behind a photic
discontinued LaValle how odd looks like
a shopping list that is odd no more
instructions for what though place Monty
Baba artifact on mantel ok Rd that place
10 candles around the fireplace recite
the phrase in Dec do ved read rev
Tirupur over or Talavera smash a
completely useless blue object in the
fireplace lose yourself ok it's just
white noise no point is staring into the
abyss while it stares back ok o quest
for Thrones Arkham's online first adult
adventure game blood sex politics and
damn it 6 3 maybe there's a save game
already on the computer couldn't hurt to
try
what is happening what's happening
the incestual twit what is happening
what well that sucks I guess this boss
is just a piece of [ __ ] thanks naughty
should know people sit stand I'll just a
static I can sit on the left side of
waiting the mouldy stain or I could just
not sit coffee table floppy disk and
store some data Arkham online just one
oh wait but there could be there's
broken okay did I just do it wrong
I don't know pretty cold outside okay
blue cop I need candles I guess I'm so
confused
Cthulhu Bob let's wipe it's mine has to
be the last thing in the cabinet a
floppy disk titled final prototype well
I can't do anything cuz it's all gone a
bookcase there's an old saying don't
open books that aren't yours else you
may be consumed by the ideas of others
no I'm sure I made that up I don't feel
like reading right now
foreboding darkness I can't do anything
with it right I'm so incredibly utterly
confused ten candles all right do I just
put them anywhere in a circle around the
fireplace that doesn't look right
not that either [ __ ] this'll do okay
seems to be more than ten candles it was
a list recite in way where's Step four
in deck do Rev Tirupur over uh or
talavera okay blue cup fireplace I'm
missing step four but I think that's for
a point probably oh where am I going
since Santa Oh Krampus
oh [ __ ] it's Krampus oh my god oh my god
maybe I should move oh oh this minigame
is a seasonal promo for our upcoming
game shadow over isolation oh yeah and I
gotta go back in because there's
obviously more to it than this but I
didn't do it right
obviously okay so now that the
computer's not broken I can go here grab
this disk but I can use the final
prototype disk I don't know what that
means
oh this game does not represent naughty
shinobi or its stories the prototype
isn't an actual game and will be not be
worked on after the final prototype
isn't released I doubt this this will
backfire are naughty shinobi who's dense
enough to not read this
it definitely backfired no one reads
anything anymore I'm reading that has to
count for all not damn it
Oh what eldritch artifact if this was an
actual full-length game I'd probably be
able to get it but it's not this is a
mini game I'm far too lazy to extend my
arms fr then again no one's gonna read
anything then complain why this game is
so short what I got 40 of 42 which is
better than I did before but I'm still
very very confused oh my god what is
that I'm so confused
cuz I don't know if they just made this
game on a whim in short order and
there's actually nothing or if I'm
actually doing it terribly I don't know
I haven't tried this disc search for
sanity oh okay well not my score is
garbage but what even does a score mean
Wow I just burnt some useless junk
oh wait am I supposed to do wait a
minute okay wait Han I'm gonna I'm gonna
close out I'm gonna go back in
[Music]
wait now I've got a score 40 wait why
we're gonna score 40 now 40 what wait
but now 42 way I am so confused now I've
got 43 I don't know why I have 43 it
doesn't make any sense
or how about Cthulhu in the fireplace
fine you weirdo blue cop all right I've
got 45 whatever that means
why do I have 45 hey you got to be nice
to me I've got 45 points you can't kill
me there's no difference there's no
difference all right whatever
okay that was oh oh it's Christmas man
that was a that was an odd assembly of
games that was very strange very strange
but honestly like I like point-and-click
horror games I don't think there's
enough of them um but that was just so
weird
I had no clear idea of what was going on
III want to see like what other stuff
they developed just to see like what the
full game that this is relating to do is
gonna be but for this like alright this
is alright guys three scare games
Christmas is now officially over we can
say this for certain it's over but scary
games will continue so thank you
everybody so much for watching if you
want to see more scary games that I've
done there is a playlist linked right
down there in the description below also
suggested videos over there
thank you again if you got scary games
do you want me to play comment the names
of those scary games thanks again and as
always I'll see you in this
but I
[Music]